you might have heard that former
baseball player and Red Sox pitcher Curt
Schilling is now a likely possible
somewhat likely future Republican Senate
candidate Curt Schilling conservative
political views are pretty widely known
here in Massachusetts maybe a little
less so nationally Curt Schilling showed
up on CNN and he just couldn't
understand for the life of him how
Jewish people can be voting for
Democrats and he wanted Jake Tapper to
explain it to him because hey Jake
Tapper is Jewish right
check out this bizarre and awkward
exchange on CNN between Republican
former baseball pitcher Curt Schilling
and Red Sox champion I might add and
Jake Tapper on CNN I want I would like
to ask you something about as a as a
person who's practicing the Jewish faith
and has since you were you were you were
young I don't understand and this is
maybe this is the amateur non-politician
to me I don't understand how people of
Jewish faith can back the Democratic
Party which over the last 50 years has
been so clearly anti-israel so clearly
anti-jewish Israel that that that it I
mean I don't know what else would need
to be done said or happen for people to
understand that they don't they're not
what the Democratic Party is allied with
Israel only because we have agreements
in place that make them have to be well
I don't speak for Jews and I don't
support the Democratic Party or the
Republican Party I would imagine just to
try to answer your question that one of
the reasons many Jews are Democrats has
more to do with Democrats support for
social welfare programs and and that
sort of thing than it does for Israel
and and I know that a lot of Jews who
are very strong supporters of Israel do
support the Republican Party but right
I'm again I'm I don't I don't speak for
Jews but but correct though and I I know
you don't but I know you do I just
always find it no it's a great
conversation to something for somebody
of your faith because I want to
understand that the reasons behind some
of those things so I appreciate that
yeah yeah no I know you don't speak for
Jews Jake but please speak for Jews and
tell me exactly why it is that Jews are
doing this the reality is that the
Democratic Party is very close to the
Republican Party on the issue of Israel
you don't see the religious ideologues
who support Israel for religious reasons
nearly as much on the Democratic side
than the Republican side but there are
some confused far leftists that are
straight-up anti Israeli and in some
cases anti-semitic you know I call it
out all the time
but the reality is that the Democratic
Party by and large is is friendly to
Israel in the United States and Pat
there's there's a lot that people just
don't seem to understand about Jews I
mean first and foremost Jews are
overwhelmingly non-religious so that is
going to make a lot of the other issues
that are relevant to progressive voters
relevant Jews and of course Judaism is a
religion but being Jewish is also an
ethnicity and a culture and by large but
by and large most Jews are quite
non-religious if someone says to you I
am a Christian that is a very very
specific and often strong religious
connotation when I say to someone I'm
Jewish I'm not talking about religion at
all and Curt Schilling just doesn't seem
to understand anything about Jews and he
really wants Jake to explain it to him
yeah exactly in a CNN interview is not
the time to be doing that I mean you're
the guest on the program yeah go home do
your research before you get on live TV
no doubt about it and then of course
often the biggest misconception about
Jews Jews make up 0.19 percent of the
world population and there are many
people and I've spoken to many of them
Jew haters and Israel haters when you
ask them hey before but you know before
we get into the details of whatever
question you might have about Jews or
Israel or whatever what portion of the
world population do you think is Jewish
and oftentimes you hear oh probably like
five percent of the world population or
oh I don't know ten percent of the world
population in some cases even 20 and
we've seen from a number of studies that
the the higher your estimation of the
Jewish population of the world
but overall right not in all cases but
overall the more Jews you think there
are in the world the more
stereotypically anti-semitic anti-jewish
beliefs that you hold that's not
everybody but that's big picture now to
get back to Curt Schilling
I actually am scared of Curt Schilling
running against Elizabeth Warren here in
Massachusetts for her Senate seat
because Massachusetts is democratic by
and large but it is not as liberal as
many people think it is more sort of
Kennedy establishment Democratic than it
is Bernie Sanders liberal in 2012 Mitt
Romney had nearly 40 percent of the vote
and when you get someone that is as
polarizing as Elizabeth Warren and
someone that is and Boston sports taken
very seriously in Massachusetts Pat as
you know as popular as Curt Schilling I
don't think this is something to laugh
off if you're an Elizabeth Warren
supporter and this is the same Curt
Schilling to who was fired from ESPN
yeah for tweeting an offensive meme
against the transgender community right
but yeah my fear is that I mean Boston
Sports is so big here and he was part of
two championship Red Sox teams yeah that
he would actually be able to defeat a
lioness in the Senate Elizabeth Warren I
hope it doesn't happen we'll be
following it and by the way Curt
Schilling holding just an embarrassingly
poorly attended Trump rally over the
weekend almost nobody showed up you can
look it up I won't even tell you more
about it but it was a laughingstock